at this altitude i can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start to
shake
can i answer your personal question
[Music]
i'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal
[Music]
this episode is brought to you by
linkedin jobs now more than ever
businesses are grappling with incredibly
challenging times
a lot of things in life and business are
changing and we're all adapting to new
priorities while it does take time to
adjust linkedin believes that it's also
possible to find and create
opportunities
in times of turbulence in times of
change whether you're looking to hire
now for a critical role
or thinking about needs that you might
have in the future linkedin jobs
can help linkedin is an active community
with more than 675 million members
worldwide linkedin screens candidates
for the hard and soft skills you're
looking for
while putting your job in front of
candidates looking for job opportunities
that match
exactly what you have to offer with
linkedin you can hire the right person
quickly
when you need them and if you need to
hire for healthcare or essential
services
you can post your jobs for free right
now
when it's time to find and hire that
right person linkedin is here to help
just visit linkedin.com tim again that's
linkedin.com tim to post a job now
terms and conditions apply
this episode is brought to you by five
bullet friday my very own email
newsletter it's become one of the most
popular email newsletters in the world
with millions of subscribers
and it's super super simple it does not
clog up your inbox every friday
i send out five bullet points super
short of the coolest things i've found
that week
which sometimes includes apps books
documentaries
supplements gadgets new self-experiments
hacks tricks
and all sorts of weird stuff that i dig
up from around the world
you guys podcast listeners and book
readers have asked me for something
short and action-packed for a very long
time because after all the podcast the
books they can be quite long
and that's why i created five bullet
friday it's become
one of my favorite things i do every
week it's
free it's always going to be free and
you can learn more at tim dot blog
forward slash friday that's tim dot blog
forward slash
friday i get asked a lot how i meet
guests for the podcast
some of the most amazing people i've
ever interacted with
and little known fact i've met probably
25 of them because they first subscribed
to fiber of friday so you'll be
in good company it's a lot of fun five
bullet friday is only available if you
subscribe
via email i do not publish the content
on the blog or anywhere else
also if i'm doing small in-person
meetups offering early access to
startups beta testing special
deals or anything else that's very
limited i share it first with five
bullet friday subscribers
so check it out tim dot blog forward
slash
friday if you listen to this podcast
it's very likely that you'd
dig it a lot and you can of course
easily subscribe any
time so easy peasy again that's tim
dot blog forward slash friday and thanks
for checking it out if the spirit moves
you
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the tim ferriss show
where it is my job to
interview people who are world-class
performers in their respective fields
and today my guest is howard marks
at howard mark's book on twitter howard
is co-chairman and co-founder of oaktree
capital management a leading investment
firm with more than 125 billion
in assets under management he is the
author of the books mastering the market
cycle subtitle getting the
odds on your side and the most important
thing
subtitle uncommon sense for the
thoughtful investor both critically
acclaimed bestsellers
warren buffett has written of howard
mark's quote when i see memos from
howard marks in my mail they're the
first thing i open and read
i always learn something so he has some
very bright minds who pay attention to
his writing
and howard has been on the podcast
before this is round
two and we dig into all sorts of
subjects including
the us dollar as reserve currency
investing how to add
defense to investment strategy three
different ways to do that
and much much more so without further
ado please enjoy a wide-ranging
conversation with
howard marks
howard welcome back to the show thank
you very much tim it's a pleasure to be
here
it's nice to hear your voice again and
uh
of all the people i could speak to on
the show
during these most exciting times and
difficult times for many people you are
very much at the top of the list
and there are a lot of different topics
and a lot of different questions that
i'd like to cover but i thought we could
start i have a number of your memos in
front of me
and there's one called you bet this is
from january 13th 2020
and i i thought we could start with the
story of arriving at first
national citibank in may of 68 and how
that contrasted
with what you then did in 1978
would you mind telling that story for
people listening
no if you have some time i do have all
the time in the world
it'll take a while um well as you say
i arrived at citibank for a summer job
in the investment research department
in may of 1968 between years of graduate
school at the university of chicago
and i was assigned to the investment
research department
the bank and
most of the money center banks at the
time in their money management
departments were adherents of what was
called nifty 50
investing and
they invested in what they considered to
be the 50
best and fastest growing companies in
america
extremely high quality companies
where nothing could go wrong and
uh you know they the the the idea of
growth stock investing investing in
companies
because their earnings grew rapidly had
been born
in the early 1960s and
these uh companies epitomized
that activity um ibm
xerox kodak polaroid merck lilly
perkin homer texas instruments uh avon
coca-cola uh aig et cetera
and um you know the
the basic idea was you hit your self to
a company with a bright future
and rapidly growing earnings and uh
if you if you did so the day i got there
in 1968
and if you held those stocks firmly for
the next five years
you lost almost all your money in the
best cup
in the best companies in america because
one thing had been overlooked in the
process
which was price and nobody
talked about the fairness
or attractiveness of the price the
belief was that these are companies
which were so good
that it didn't matter what you paid
and if you paid a price that was a bit
high the earnings
would grow so fast that kind of the
stock would grow into the price
and uh so of course this was a
painful education these stocks
generally speaking fell from price
earnings ratios of
perhaps 80 which even today would be
practically unheard of to eight
when the wheels came off the market in
the early 1970s now some of it
some of it was the collapse of the
market some of it was the collapse
of uh these this particular uh
field of investing and some was that
function of the
flowering of rapid inflation which was
perplexing
uh the country at that time but but for
whatever reason
here you are you're you're investing in
the best companies in america
and you lose 80 or 90 percent of your
money
now fast forward as you suggest tim to
1978
in part because my uh
meanderings with equities had worked out
so badly as part of the
uh machinery that
that ran this nifty 50 effort i
uh left the investment research
department
i always say i'm lucky i didn't get
fired and
my boss asked me to join the bond
department
which was at that time a backwater of
investing
and start a fund that would invest in
convertible bonds
which was something that very few people
had ever heard of
and i started to do that and i loved it
so i went from
being head of a department of
75 people with a 5 million budget and
membership on all the bank senior
investment committees to working alone
with no colleagues no budget no
committees
and i was ecstatic because rather than
know two sentences on 400 companies
i could know everything about a few
so i i loved money management and i
loved the fact that i was
operating in in an uncrowded area
and then in august of 1978 i got the
call to change my life the head of the
bond department called up and he said
you know there's a guy named milken or
something out in california
and he deals with something called
high-yield bonds do you think you could
figure out what that is
because a client had asked for a
high-yield bond portfolio
so i i researched high yield bonds i
met with mike milken i started
citibank's
high yield bond fund late in 1978
i believe that was the first high yield
bond fund from the mainstream financial
institution
and that was the very beginning of the
high yield bond world
and one of the great lessons of course
as malcolm gladwell
makes clear in his book uh
outliers is that it's great to be first
in line
and the timing
accident of my being assigned to the
bond department in 1978 put me
at the beginning of the line in high
yield bonds
and io bonds are the bonds of companies
which are
not rated investment grade they're
considered speculative grade
by the rating agencies at the time they
were verboten
by the vast majority of investors and
so i went from investing in what
everybody loved
to what everybody hated
from the best companies in america to
the worst public companies in america
and now i'm making money safely and
steadily
in the worst companies in america
because
they were so cheap because the interest
rates they had to pay in order to secure
financing
as as a
a disrespected group was
excessive under the circumstances
so this was quite an epiphany
and it has uh really directed my whole
career
and you've you've written in
this particular memo success in gambling
doesn't go to those who pick winners but
to those with the ability to identify
superior propositions
the goal is to find situations where the
odds are generous to one side or the
other
whether favorite or underdog in other
words a mispricing
and you explore this in the context
of different types of games some games
of chance
some games that have different profiles
and
you can categorize them you have let's
just say
no hidden information no luck and skill
chess no hidden information luck and
skill backgammon no hidden information
luck no skill roulette hidden
information luck skill
blackjack and poker and you have quite a
history with
many different types of games and you i
think are very good
at thinking about the future
probabilistically
framing good questions if you were to
look at our current circumstances as a
game
and perhaps compare it to 2008
what are the games that we're looking at
well it's it's an it's a very
interesting
uh set of circumstances we find
ourselves in
because nobody knows anything about the
future
there's you know in the fields that i'm
involved in
economics and investing primarily there
is no such thing as knowledge of the
future
because the future does not operate
according to a fixed schedule
or the laws of nature like physics and
so forth
all we have is extrapolation from past
patterns
which help us in terms of our
expectations
for the future the problem we have
now is that there is no history for what
we're engaged in
first of all we have
i would say the worst public health
crisis
to come to america in over 100 years or
certainly one of the worst
the worst economy since the great
depression
more than 80 years old
the worst collapse of oil in history
and the greatest rescue and stimulus
program
from the fed and the treasury in history
so we have four things going on
which are unprecedented
and as a result we really can't
say what lies ahead in any of them
and it is further complicated by the
fact that they'll
interact and we can't
know how they will interact and what
that will produce
so uh i i would say that we are uh
unusually ignorant with regard to the
future
today and uh you know one of the things
i said to one of my colleagues tim
is that we all have the same information
about
the present and we all have the same
ignorance about the future
and today i think that ignorance is is
greater than at other times
so we have to um
to use the the uh outline you were
posing
there's a lot of hidden information we
don't even know how many people really
have it we don't know how many people
have died from it
because there are unreported cases of
infection
and there are deaths that took place
that were not
known to be the result of infection so
we have
we have hidden information and we have
so much about the future that we don't
know uh you know
will the will the disease turn down will
the
the effect of warm weather be a positive
when will
a a uh an immunological test be
developed and a vaccine
if we reopen business will
the cases that strike up again
and so forth and to what extent so uh
we're really
dealing with a lot of ignorance
and a lot of uncertainty
and yet we have to take action
in positioning our capital for the
future
when the future is unusually
unpredictable
and how do you how are you currently
thinking in bets to use the title of the
annie duke book
that i know you are a fan of or
uh perhaps it's not the the best way to
address the the question really but
given the uncertainties given the
situation
how are you trying to navigate that or
what questions you finding
most helpful sure well i think a lot of
it
goes back tim to what you said uh
about the memo you bet is that it has to
do with the quality of the proposition
i wrote a book we talked about it a year
and a half ago
called mastering the market cycle
and i thought that the top the subtitle
of that book
was unusually helpful the subtitle is
getting the odds on your side
when you're dealing with the future
given the ignorance
uh you can never have certainty there's
nothing that's sure to work or share to
fail
you only have probabilities but
sometimes the probabilities are very
favorable
to the investor and sometimes they are
very unfavorable
to the investor and the whole thing
about studying
cycles is trying to figure out which is
which
so let's let's talk about propositions
and let's talk about picking winners
so you go to a horse race and there's
one horse
that stands out among all the others
it great lineage looks terrific
great recent record and this horse is by
far the favorite
and everybody concludes that this horse
will win the race
does that mean that you should bet on
this horse that's really the key
question
in in investing and the answer is
it depends on the odds because
when one horse is an overwhelming
favorite you may have to bet five
dollars
to win a dollar he's so sure to win but
no nobody wants the bet against him
and if you want to join the hordes who
want to bet
on that horse as i say you may have to
put up five bucks to get back six
there may be a long shot in that race
that somebody can figure out well maybe
that horse is gonna have his day
and that horse may be a 10 to one shot
or a 50 to one shot because we're so
sure the favorite will win
that the that this this long shot uh
is absolutely unpredicted to win nobody
wants to bet on this horse so if you
will bet on this horse
and you put up a dollar you can get 50
if you're right so even though the horse
is unlikely to win
it may be the better bet even though the
favorite is overwhelmingly likely to win
it may be a bad bet
so it's not only what you think will
happen but it's also the payoffs
so let's take that through what we were
just discussing
1968 the the
nifty 50 companies were believed to be
great companies with a bright future
and let's assume that their future
success was assured
you still have to look at the
proposition
and the answer is that it costs so much
to bet on those companies
that betting on what we're believed to
be good companies
turned out to be bad bets 1978
high yield bonds now we're betting on
what are believed to be bad companies
but because they're believed to be bad
companies the payoff is extremely
generous
not not expected to be favorites
but highly remunerative if they pay off
so high yield bond investing was very
successful
now you come into the into the present
and and life gets tough but you know
we have to make some judgments about the
future
and the judgment you have to you have to
say how bad will it get
now how quickly will we go back to work
what will be the experience when we go
back to work
will there be rebounding cases how
quickly will the economy
come back to life what
will gnp do in the second quarter of
this year which is
roundly believed to be the worst
recession quarter
in history and how fast will we get back
to the
2019 levels of economic activity
and surpass them when will we have a
vaccine all the
you know there there are dozens of
questions
um and no answers
um i've been quoting uh mark lipsich
who's a uh epidemiologist at harvard
who says that when in studying the virus
there are there are facts
there are inferences based on analogies
to other viruses
and there are opinions
and when we started off in this round
there were no facts
the highly skilled epidemiologist could
make inferences
and the rest of us were left to just
guess
but you know there's there's some
um consensus developing
which is that you know the country will
go back to work
in the next few months
clearly no agreement on the pace
that there will be likely to be a
rebound
in new cases but not as bad as the first
and that gradually the economy will
recover
and it'll show
much better 2021 than 2020
2021 may or may not be back to the 2019
levels
but by 2022 we'll be back to
or surpass the 2019 levels and with
vaccines and treatments
the coronavirus
will be demoted to just another seasonal
disease that's the consensus and
of course the consensus opinion is
reflected
in the bidding for stocks
and in the prices of stocks and other
securities
and that's where we are now um and uh
you know that so that's i would say i
would describe that as a fairly
uh positive forward-looking case
um and it's incorporated in the prices
of stocks
and the prices of stocks are
surprisingly high
some of them or if you look at the the
averages which are dominated by
you know the great companies like amazon
and microsoft those averages like the s
p 500 are surprisingly high
relative to where they were on february
19th which was the all-time high
and we're probably down um
you know low double digits of percent 12
13 14
uh percent depending on the date you air
this
um and uh so you know
the way i've described it i would say uh
not a bad outcome
not a bad future and uh
so stocks have recovered very
substantially from their lows they're up
uh 27 i think from their lows
uh because the consensus has settled on
this
uh good news um now the now let's talk
for a minute if i can go on
about proposition the challenge today
is that if the favorable
unfolds and 2021 or 22
are healthy economically
versus 19. nobody thinks the stock
market
has that far to go on the upside
and if the negative case
unfolds and everything i've said
so promisingly uh fails to materialize
or materializes less
and later than hoped
there are pessimists who think that the
market has far to fall
and it's hard to choose between the
optimistic and the pessimistic case
so uh the odds for buying here
the s p 500 for example do not seem
to me to be tilted heavily in the
investor's favor
now you have been thinking about
uncertainty for a very very long time
you for instance first read
a book in 1963
titled decisions under uncertainty
subtitled drilling decisions by
oil and gas operators by c jackson
grayson jr
and you've you've proven inability
to act on a
sort of spectrum of uncertainty over the
subsequent decades and i think the way
that you phrase
questions is part of that questions to
yourself
questions among your team and i just
wanted to give an example of that
from your most recent memo
this is knowledge of the future and it's
it's a paragraph that's discussing
the word limitless which was
uh used i think in quoting fed chairman
or
uh some someone of that type and
here's here's the the wording is the
program really limitless and is that
okay
the stimulus loans bailouts benefits and
bond buying that have been announced
thus far add up to several trillion
dollars what are the implications of the
result in additions to the federal
deficit in the fed's balance sheet
here's the part that i want to highlight
just because i think it's a
useful i think it's a useful framework
for
looking at a lot of these a lot of these
elements okay so here we go to be
facetious the government could send
every american a check for 1 million at
a cost of 330 trillion would there be
any negative consequences from doing
this such as burgeoning inflation a
downgrade of u.s creditworthiness
or the dollar losing its status as the
world's reserve currency
if the answer is yes is there a point
below 330 trillion at which those
ramifications might kick in and if so
where could we be there already
i i'd be very curious to hear how you've
attempted to
answer or think about any of those
things that were mentioned
in that paragraph we could pick one
certainly if it's helpful such as
the u.s dollar the status of the dollar
as a reserve currency
in uh in in these wildly
unusual times but how have you continued
to
think about those questions or attempt
to tackle some of those
unknowns well this is the 64 question
these days tim
uh i want to make it clear before i try
to do so
that i'm not saying the fed is wrong to
do what it's doing
the fed is throwing everything in the
kitchen sink
at the problem and the problem has to be
has to be solved uh you know back if
if i go back to march let's say
18 or 19 i think it was you know i was
actively considering the possibility
uh with my partner bruce karcz
of a global depression comparable to the
1930s and you
recall that we had we had a decade with
uh unemployment in excess of 14 percent
in the u.s
and a total absence of growth and
widespread suffering
and uh you know we were talking about
the possibility of that
as this economy uh contracted
imploded so the the fed and the treasury
came along
they threw everything at it they used
all the lessons learned
in the global financial crisis of all
809
things that were developed over the
course of months at that time
were implemented in weeks this time and
uh certainly
uh you know i think it was the uh new
york times describing
uh uh jay powell statement
as saying that the resources thrown at
the problem would be limitless and
i think that's the right thing because
the alternative
uh you know back in the 30s they were
judicious
in trying to fight the depression almost
austere
and um as a result
a decade of suffering a generation
truly scarred uh and um
you know arguably we only got out of the
depression because of the arrival of
world war ii
we don't want to wait for that as a
curative
so i say strongly that the fed
and treasury were right in doing
what they did but uh the fact that
there may be negative unintended
consequence
doesn't mean that they weren't right but
you know again
we are we're battling problems we've
never seen before
with weapons we've never seen before
and we certainly can't
say that they don't have
negative potential uh unintended
consequences
we just we don't know what they are we
will
we would probably bear them nevertheless
but
for example if the government
floods prints money the normal reflex
reaction is to say that if they print a
lot of money
that causes the currency to be devalued
and that that that is a
lockstep relationship that has always
been
considered now in the last
you know we've been running big deficits
for a long time and extremely big
deficits in
recent years uh and
yet we don't have
serious inflation which is the normal
sign
of of a currency being debased if the
currency is
being debated and people think less of
it and then if they
if you if you want to buy a goat you
have to pay more dollars
to get the goat or a car or a bar of
gold or
whatever and or you know
a bunch of bananas and in recent years
we haven't had inflation even though
we've been running huge deficits
vastly increasing the national debt and
and so forth
so you know economics is not a
mechanical process
which works according to a schematic in
a dependable fashion
and all the printing of money
that has taken place in recent years has
not
brought on inflation inflation is
supposed to
work in response to the unemployment
rate the less unemployment there is in
the country the higher the inflation is
supposed to be because
there's less slack in the economy and
the uh workers for example can demand
higher wages
hasn't happened that was this is just
something uh
called the phillips curve and it's been
having for
60 years and just doesn't work
so we don't know uh but you know
that's why i use that extreme and i say
said in the memo facetious example
if the government sent everybody a check
for a million dollars
and it cost 330 trillion would there be
an effect on the value of the dollar on
inflation
etc and you have to believe there would
or i have to believe there would but
where does the negative effect cut in
short of that since we're not going to
do that
but you know the government is probably
spending
on buying securities and pumping
into the economy you know close to
10 trillion this year is that enough to
cause an impact
and the answer is we don't know but i
would just say you know
it's clear that we all have our biases
and we
deal with our uncertainty with regard to
the future
implementing our biases it's very hard
to get away from that
and i worry i'm not a dreamer i'm not a
pollyanna i'm not the person who says oh
they'll find a solution
i worry and so uh you know i
worry that there will be some negative
uh effects that i can't predict or
or describe or quantify and so that
would
among other things uh tend to
cause me to implement some caution and
uh
you're right the fed chairman jay pal to
his his ex his quote
was when it comes to lending we're not
going to run out of ammunition
which was in the wall street journal
that's on march
30th uh what what form might that
caution take
or perhaps more specifically if we look
at
the fed buying all sorts of things that
historically it would would not
necessarily be associated with
purchasing junk bonds distressed debt
etc how does
how does that affect your
playbook and how you think about crowded
versus uncrowded
opportunities sure so many things in
that question
require an answer um first
let me say that i think every investor
has to make a choice they have to
balance
offense and defense just like just like
a
a soccer team that a coach feels to play
against another team
uh you know you have to have the
players on the field who in totality
can both defend their goal
and attack the other side's goal
so your portfolio for the investor
has to strike a balance between
trying to make money and trying to avoid
losing money at the same time
and the way i dope it out
tim is to say that every investor faces
two risks
every day the risk of losing money
which is obvious and the risk of missing
opportunity
which is a little more subtle now you
can eliminate either risk
if you are willing to totally surrender
to the other risk
so i can if you want to if you want to
eliminate the risk of losing money you
can put all your money into t-bills
and then you will miss all the
opportunities
or if you want to make sure you don't
miss any opportunities you can make sure
that all your investments are
aggressive and there are no t bills or
cash in which case
you're exposed heavily to the
possibility of losing money
so most people compromise most people
say well
i don't want to lose a lot of money but
on the other hand i don't want to miss
all the opportunities so i'm going to
strike a balance
between offense and defense that's what
we all have to do if we're not crazy
and so the question is
how do you strike that balance today
and um oaktree my
firm in recent years has been concerned
about the market and
about the fact that we thought that it
was
exposed to significant uncertainties and
risks
although we didn't enumerate pandemic
that
asset prices were high that prospective
returns were
low because interest rates in the
environment
have been so low for so long and because
a lot of investors were engaging in
risky behavior
in order to make a good return in a low
return world
so you put all that together and we
thought that made the world a risky
low return place in which one should
emphasize defense over offense
and and we did we we adopted a mantra
move forward but with caution
and that has guided us now we are
cautious investors so when i say with
caution
i mean more than usual and that's what
we've done
next question how do you implement
defense
and there are basically three ways that
an
investor can add to
defense in his portfolio or her
portfolio
the first the obvious one is you sell
some assets
and you go to cash in part or in whole
now this is very hard to do because this
is
black or white wrong or right
and rarely is it right
to be overwhelmingly in cash and on the
rare
occasions when it's right most people
can't find those occasions
so so going to cash is problematic and
by the way if you go to cash and you're
wrong and you
you miss good performance in the market
for a couple of years
uh you know the individual investor will
rule the day and the professional
investor
might be out of work so cash is tough
the next thing you can do is you can go
into more
defensive asset classes we know what
they are
more bonds rather than stocks
larger companies rather than small
value rather than growth stable rather
than cyclical
us rather than foreign developed world
rather than emerging
and you know there are many many ways
to increase the defensiveness of your
asset allocation
and then the third form of going
defensive
doesn't even require you to disturb your
asset allocation
it's just that everything you want to do
in investing
can be done in a more aggressive or more
defensive way
so you might say well i have 40 of my
portfolio in stocks and i want to keep
it that way
but you can buy more defensive stocks
or you can put your money with a more
defensive manager
or you can put your money in a mutual
fund
which has a record of not making so much
money in the up years
but protecting money in the down years
so there are three ways to be defensive
go to cash take a more defensive asset
allocation
or use more defensive tactics um
and we've been doing the latter our
asset allocation is assigned our clients
give us money and they say here put this
in this or put this in that
for the most part we don't choose our
asset allocation
but what we've been doing is in in
recent years we have been
fully invested and so we participated as
the market rose
but with a portfolio that we think was
more defensive
than most and so we came into
this uh virus episode
with a higher quality more defensive
portfolio
and that stood us quite well in
in the in the first quarter but
frankly with the risks on the table
and a lot of securities now cheaper than
they used to be
and a lot of risky behavior now
discouraged
uh i don't think one has to be as
defensive as we were
so we have shifted the balance in our
portfolios
move more on to offense to take
advantage
and if if you're looking towards offense
uh capitalizing on some of your
historic strengths what does the how
does the fed purchasing
all sorts of asset classes that it might
not normally purchase affect
how you look at those opportunities if
uh sure
that was part of your original question
which i forgot
but um well you know as
as should be clear you know we're
specialists
in non-gilt-edge debt
guilt edge is an old-fashioned term
non-investment-grade debt speculative
grade debt
and um you know that means high-yield
bonds
uh leveraged loans convertible bonds
which i have mentioned before
um you know emerging market debt
lots of lots of let's say less than
stellar
quality debt and usually in a crisis
like this
that stuff would be hurt more than most
which meant that we could pick it up
cheaper than most
perhaps our one of our flagship
strategies
is investing in distressed debt the debt
of companies that are
either bankrupt in default
or highly likely to be in the opinion
of the market and we've been investing
in distressed debt
uh since 1988 uh
my partner bruce cars joined me in 87
he's been running these portfolios since
then
and uh in the 32 years there were five
periods
uh when there were very high defaults
among high-yield bonds
a lot of the stress and when we got to
take advantage of very good
opportunities and those were 1990-91
2001 02 and 08 those were crisis years
and in the crises the low quality risky
debt tended to melt down and we tended
to
get great buying opportunities so your
question is well what does it mean
that the fed is involving itself in
these areas and the answer is it's
if we wish they'd go away uh you know
because
because it you know historically in in
negative times
uh and this is something we haven't
discussed much but
maybe we should uh most people get
discouraged
most people uh shrink to the sidelines
and uh you know when when when these
things would cascade down in price
we would be able to buy them very
cheaply if the fed comes in
and buys in those markets then it makes
our lives more difficult
because things don't fall the way they
otherwise would have we don't get the
bargains
we otherwise would have when you look uh
well i mean i mean i want to ask if you
think
the fed is truly with
infinite ammo i mean i don't know if
they have the the
sort of bandwidth to participate super
widely indefinitely
in high volume but possibly they do this
is way outside of my
area of expertise so it's a bit above my
pay grade but
where would you thinking
probabilistically where would you
how do you look at the possible outcomes
and probabilities
that this type of spending
continues for a long period of time
i think that the the the fed and the
treasury
want to soften the impact on america
and its economy and i think they're
going to continue to spend
uh until the economy
is can take over for itself i think one
way to think of this tim
is that you know many times if a patient
has a serious disease
they'll put the patient into a coma so
that they can treat the disease
and while the patient's in the coma they
keep them on life support
and then when the patient is
the disease has been healed the patient
can be brought back and the life support
can be removed
so the disease is the virus
in order to fight the virus
we had to close businesses freeze
economic activity and tell people to
stay home
so stores movies and hotels
and airlines and concerts and sports
all stopped cold
and that's putting the economy into a
coma
and we have 26 million people who have
filed for unemployment insurance in the
last five weeks
and uh we are expecting a decline of gdp
uh in the second quarter here of
well most people say 20 to 30 percent
which would
make it the worst quarter in history by
a
order of magnitude so they have to
keep it on life support until they can
bring the economy back
and the life support is all this
injection
from the fed and the treasury and
they're going to continue it until
they're
highly confident that they're out of the
woods they're not going to take a chance
and say well if we let's let's suspend
it now
and see if the economy can pick up
they're going to wait until the economy
is operating with some strength and
growing from this depressed base before
they withdraw it
i'm confident of that what are the as
someone who's
i i've never taken an economics class
which is
not something i brag about it's quite uh
something a source of embarrassment for
me but
what are the markers or metrics that
they would
look to to assess whether the patient
can be taken off of life support
well unemployment is is usually the best
short-term indicator you know uh
remember that unemployment reached 10
percent in the global financial crisis
uh and it was down to five percent five
five to five and a half is it has
generally been considered something like
a structural level of unemployment in
other words there are people
there are some people who can't get a
job because they're unqualified
there are people who can't get a job
because they can't pass a drug test
there are people who just quit a job
there are people in the process of
looking for a job so
transactional frictionally most people
assume that five
five-ish percent is is uh is structural
and the
obama administration uh over eight years
did get
the unemployment rate i believe down to
five percent uh
by 2016 and then uh a trump
administration
came in and uh continued uh very
aggressive stimulus uh pro-business uh
environment
reduction of regulation and the
unemployment got down to three and a
half
so it's a barometer of how the economy
is doing
and i would think that the they'll want
well it's you see it's not going to be
all or nothing it's not
they're not going to spend spend spend
and then stop
they'll slack off the term we use if it
in the in the
discipline you never studied economics
is taper
and they'll taper but you know i think
that they'll support
the economy certainly aggressively
until the unemployment rate gets into
single digits
and perhaps until it gets into
mid-single digits
and then of course they'll look at gdp
they'll you know
gdp has been growing at around two
percent and donald trump has been trying
to
say he'll get it to three or four um
but gdp will be deceptive because
you know it's going to be so horrible in
the second quarter
of 20 that it's going to be easy to show
growth
in the second quarter of 21 but we we
have to take that
growth with the grain of salt and i
think what they'll look for
is for the gdp to be getting close
back to the track that it was on
if this virus hadn't developed
you're you've listed some questions
that uh debt traders on the oak tree
team justin quagliaf i'm saying that
correctly sam rotolo
that are related to behavioral change
more than anything else so assuming that
quarantine is lifted when will you take
your first flight how will you react
when the person next to you starts
coughing
what has to happen to make you feel it's
safe to send your child back to school
one of my favorites is the when you go
to a dinner with your wife husband
friend family do you want to be served
by a waiter or waitress wearing masking
gloves
so these are behavioral questions and
you seem to be a connoisseur of
questions
and i i want to bring up a quote that
also
was featured in the you can't predict
you can prepare memo which was
what the wise man does in the beginning
the fool does
in the end and these these might not be
totally uh apples to apples but what
types of questions
are the whys asking
these days are any particular types of
thinking or
questions present in those people
you had you admire as good thinkers
right now well the
you know the future the outlook for the
economy
has been mostly described as a v
sharp down in the first and second
quarter
uh of uh 2020 maybe some lingering
effects in the third
and then sharp up and uh you know
there's a lot of debate
about how sharp
the the recovery will be um
you know i think i i personally think
we're going to come back
gradually i think that people who have a
choice
are not going to rush back to work one
of the questions that you didn't
ask from that memo tim was was mine
uh for a new yorker when are you going
to get back on the subway
right that's a great question and and
and be in close contact with all those
other people
um and you know taking an airplane
flight is
is a big deal because you know they want
you to be six feet
away from the next person and i the way
i calculated it
uh at best you could have one person for
every nine seats
and they're not going to do that of
course they'll fill the seats
and they'll have people wearing masks uh
but
um you know uh i think that people who
have a choice are gonna
wait a while before they get on a full
airplane
uh another question of course is
assuming that there is a reopening and
assuming that the
that the virus hasn't been killed off
and we don't have yet a
vaccine um will people
engage in their previous activities i
think that people who have a choice will
not
rush back um and then you
i read about one state that that passed
a rule that restaurants can reopen but
only one out of every four tables
can be occupied but also an article
yesterday which said that a
business which is operating at a low
level of its capacity is probably not
more profitable than it was when it was
closed yeah
that's definitely true that's definitely
true here in austin
a lot of restaurants are opting not to
open with
25 capacity right right so
you know uh the
the expectation that we're going to come
back
is probably right but nobody knows the
pace
and these are important questions to ask
but you know one of these days i assume
i assume we'll have a vaccine it's not
easy to produce
330 million doses and get them
into distribution or if we need
two like you do for shingles for example
there's 660 million
doses and um you know these are massive
issues and they don't happen overnight
um and then of course
you know we have large numbers of people
who don't you know only
only half of americans i think get flu
shots uh
where where flu shots are flu kills a
lot you know
kills a lot of americans i think flu
probably averages 40 to 50 000 deaths a
year
and yet only half the people get the
shots um
will people get the shots uh and uh
you know there's a there's an
anti-vaccine uh
cohort in america and will they get them
and so forth and
if they don't what does it imply for
everybody else
so i just think that it's you know when
what i say about these unprecedented
events tim is that if you haven't seen
something happen in the past you can't
say you know how it's going to turn out
and we have to we have to allow windage
now a warrior like me
allows for the possibility of bad
outcomes
an optimist wants to make sure he
contemplates the possibility of good
outcomes surprisingly good outcomes
and so that's why we have indifferences
of opinion that's uh
that's why uh you know that we have
markets
in which people can can meet and express
their opinion through price
uh just just a few more questions howard
i i appreciate that all the time today
the the question of informational
filtering
is one i'd like to chat about for a
second what i mean by that is how do you
choose
amongst a deluge of possible books
articles
sources of information what you
read these days for instance or a better
question is probably what are
some of the higher signal sources of
information
books people anything that you're paying
attention to these days
well you know there there are no i don't
think there are
useful topical books on the subject
of this episode yet it's too new
we have to you know always review our
thinking how we think about propositions
and odds and bets and probabilities and
how we think about making decisions
under uncertainty and these kinds of
things and you've talked about
some of those um you know i think that
we all have to
take in a lot of
input primarily through the newspapers
and of course we have to be aware of the
biases
of the newspapers when i was a boy i
used to believe that it was
in the newspaper it was true but you
know newspapers have slants too
and then importantly we have to be very
aware of our own slants
um and
you know we tend to we have what's
called confirmation bias
and we all tend to read
the things we agree with more than the
things we disagree with
and believe the things that support our
biased position more than the things to
throw it into question
and this is uh this is a great challenge
um
so we we should try to read broadly
we should try to read from the newspaper
whose
editorial slant we agree with and the
one
we disagree with and we should try to
appreciate all the input but i think
it's
this is a great challenge and um
you know if you if you if you read
broadly and
everybody on the on the internet every
every brokerage and securities house is
putting out its own
coveted report nowadays and you see
such disparate information by the way
there are probably i don't know we've
been you've been talking to me about
questions at atm there are probably
100 or 200 300 questions
that bear on the future and nobody can
take them all into account
so which ones do you
think about well number one your
selection of the questions to ponder
will be
shaped by your bias uh because you can't
do them
all so you know it's
it's a terribly challenging thing uh and
um i think a lot about bias
um and let's go back to what
i said earlier uh
quoting professor lipsich of harvard
facts analogies
guesses um you know when i read
layman investment people talking about
the likely
medical course of
development you know i i say well
where's their expertise
but you know everybody has an opinion
and you can't argue you're right but on
the other hand
you can't say well i i'm not an expert
so i'm not going to have an opinion
and you know it's very very difficult
to decide these things in a
uniquely uncertain environment like
today's
well howard i i i really appreciate you
carving out time for the conversation uh
i i think that
we could cover a thousand additional
topics but
i'll just ask one more or maybe two more
and that is what would you hope people
would
think more about uh or what aren't
people paying enough attention to
in your mind is does anything does
anything occur to you
well just in in the narrow field of
investing
um you know most people want to hear
somebody like me say by yourself um
but it's it's a much more nuanced
question than that
uh you know the person who wants advice
has to think for themselves
do i want to put a lot of emphasis on
making sure i don't lose money or do i
want to make a lot of
put a lot of emphasis on making sure
that i take advantage of the
opportunities
and those two things work in opposite
directions as i explained before so
the the person
has to decide for themselves uh how they
feel about these things now they can
they can ask for advice but they
everybody has to decide this on a
personal basis
and the other thing is whether you
should buy
or sell has a lot to do with
uh number one your current position
so i i mentioned that that oak tree
became more aggressive
because we had been very defensive if
you have
been aggressive until now
that doesn't mean you should necessarily
become even more aggressive
so you know what's what's becoming
increasing aggressiveness for us may not
be right
for everybody and then the other thing
is is uh
the investor has to ask themselves and
be
tough on themselves to spec out what
their time frame is
because you know if you say to me
how how are we going to look in five
years i think in five years we're going
to be okay
and so you know if you if you said to me
i'm going to put on the position today
and i'm not going to look at it for five
years i'd say okay well then you
you should have a pretty normal
non-defensive
investment posture if you're gonna look
every
day and if you're gonna get upset
if the market goes down then you might
want to have a little more defensiveness
than normal
so again the the same answer is not
right for everybody because it depends
on
their ability to take a long-term view
rather than short
and their ability to live with the
adjective
of short-term ups and downs well thank
you very much
howard people can find you on twitter at
howard mark's book
certainly i'll link to your writing to
your book and everything else in the
show notes including
any of the memos and references that we
made
in this conversation is there anything
else you would like to add or anything
else you would like to suggest
that people take a look at no
uh you know tim's good to link to all
the memos there's a
30 years worth in the archive at
oaktreecapital.com
it's free so you can
the price is right and and you can look
at what i was
what i was thinking at various points in
time in the last 30 years
i i want to thank you tim for inquiring
about these things and asking such good
questions
these are difficult topics they're even
difficult to
frame the questions and i want to
apologize for the
length of my answers but there are never
easy answers and that's especially true
today so thank you for having me with
you
oh my pleasure howard and to everybody
listening
as always everything will be in the show
notes tim dot blog forward slash
podcast and until next time thanks for
tuning in
hey guys this is tim again just a few
more things before you take off
number one this is five bullet friday
do you want to get a short email from me
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every friday
that provides a little morsel of fun
before the weekend
and five bullet friday is a very short
email where i share
the coolest things i've found or that
i've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that i've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that i've somehow
dug up in the uh the world of the
esoteric as i do
it could include favorite articles that
i've read
and that i've shared with my close
friends for instance
and it's very short it's just a little
tiny bite
of goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to four
hourworkweek.com that's
4hourworkweek.com all spelled out and
just drop in
your email and you'll get the very next
one and if you sign up
i hope you enjoy it this episode is
brought to you by linkedin jobs
now more than ever businesses are
grappling with incredibly challenging
times
a lot of things in life and business are
changing and we're all adapting
to new priorities while it does take
time to adjust linkedin believes that
it's also possible to find and create
opportunities
in times of turbulence in times of
change whether you're looking to hire
now for a critical role
or thinking about needs that you might
have in the future linkedin jobs
can help linkedin is an active community
with more than 675 million members
worldwide linkedin screens candidates
for the hard and soft skills you're
looking for
while putting your job in front of
candidates looking for job opportunities
that match
exactly what you have to offer with
linkedin you can hire the right person
quickly
when you need them and if you need to
hire for healthcare or essential
services
you can post your jobs for free right
now
when it's time to find and hire that
right person linkedin is here to help
just visit linkedin.com tim again that's
linkedin.com
tim to post a job now terms and
conditions apply
you